we know seneca mainly from the works
that are attributed to him in his
creations there is a clear attempt to
empower the individual narrative through
a belief in virtue presence patience and
the embrace of human struggle as an
inevitable and much needed tenet of life
take this simple yet profound statement
for instance all cruelty springs from
weakness
weak is dangerous because usually
weakness can lead to cruelty it is
because of weakness that we engage in
immoral and atrocious acts it is because
of weakness that we fail to establish a
canonical set of rules in our
relationships that can help them prosper
it is because of weakness that we fail
to see our own weaknesses and we stay
trapped in a distorted version of
reality that propels us towards misery
and distress strength of character
demands resilience and appreciation of
life a responsibility towards people who
admire you and a constant fight to
achieve self-ownership this is what
seneca fought for and this is probably
what he died for